Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians, thank you for joining us today for our 27th episode!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
For first-time Ruffians!
First-time Ruffians?
First-time Ruffians.
Ruffians that are here for the first time.
Yes!
That's what makes you a first-time Ruffian.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show that's held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
A new start to a new day of a new month.
Has he been around recently?
We haven't seen him, but... A Pero Sighting!
De-den!
Pero was found at a cat cafe.
That's nice.
It looks like he was seen trying so hard to fit in with the other cats that he even glued whiskers to his face.
That's kinda uncool, Pero.
Did he do it because he's lonely?
Or because he wants to get closer to the cats?
Or did he do it because he wants the cute girls to visit the cafe to pet him?
That's not good.
You know, to glue whiskers on his face, that's pretty desperate.
Why?
What do you think, Ruffians?
You think that Pero is fine just the way he is, right?
He doesn't need the whiskers, right?
Right!
Kick him out!
What if he just wants to enjoy the cats too, huh?
Pero's just... Pero's Pero, you know?
A stern talking to it.
Well, I don't see any Ruffians saying that Pero's just fine the way he is, you know.
Well, right.
Well, you know, I think Pero's fine.
He's nasty.
But it'll be okay, right?
One day Pero'll be nice.
I think he's fine in the shape and the way he is.
His personality could get a bit of a makeover.
But we're all, you know, we're all our own individual.
And that should be something that we're all very proud of, you know?
Right?
Ruffians, why didn't you say that?
Pero's gonna be upset if you don't say it.
Don't say that, you know?
Ruffians, remember, okay?
At the very least, we shouldn't really have to worry about that.
But he does have a big tongue.
But the cats should be safe, yeah.
They should be.
But if we were in a cafe, it's a bit of a different story.
But they're safe from Pero, it's good.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Please let us know if you see Pero around again.
You can let us know with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
October!
It's October!
And with that...
It's a new month!
New hopes, yeah!
You know, and this is the first October FUWAMOCO Morning today, too!
And yeah, like we mentioned, you know, a new month brings new hopes and dreams and goals that we want to reach, too!
Did you spend some time to reflect on how September went for you, Ruffians?
We know that some people might think it's silly, but we think that reflecting is a really good habit.
We do it often, right?
What did you think of your September high?
Were you able to reach your goals?
You know, what went well, what could've been better.
I think for most people, and even us of course, you know, I don't think everything goes perfectly all the time.
But you know, we were tired in September.
And some things went well, other things could've been better.
So, let's take some time, think about it, and figure out.
What do we want for October?
Exactly.
How can we better aim for that, you know?
I think, for us, for FUWAMOCO, we want to focus more on our guard dog training, right?
Yeah.
Right.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Maybe.
I don't know, maybe not.
Maybe, maybe yes, maybe not, maybe.
But, you're gonna have to hold our paw for that, okay?
It's gonna be tough, so, okay?
You're good for it.
For the eye.
Ruffians!
Oh, that looks like Ruffians' eye.
Okay.
We'll work hard on that for October, okay?
But we also want to work on our sleeping habits and patterns so we can be more effective guard dogs and protect even more Ruffian smiles, okay?
I think you know.
Also, in October, maybe it sounds a bit weird too, but they really like to lean on the other members more too.
I know.
After talking to them, we're always so happy.
So it would be nice.
Let's work hard towards becoming even stronger together for October, okay, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
It's October.
Bye.
Actually there was some really good news.
Happy news!
I don't know if you realize, Ruffians, but...
We have over 100 videos on our FUWAMOCO channel now!
Wow, Ruffians!
It's only two months and we already have over 100 videos!
Right!
So fast!
Thank you for supporting us, Ruffians!
Thank you!
You know, it's not quite 100 livestreams, including no membership and unarchived streams yet, but...
Soon.
Very soon for sure.
We'll be there!
We can't wait until we hit 1,000 videos someday in 5-5 years.
But if we hit 100 in 2 months, then can't you do the math?
20 months?
What's the math on that, Ruffians?
Do the math!
I don't think it's gonna be something that you can just solve with a math equation, though.
Math equation?
Math equation.
I don't think so, you know.
20 months.
One year and eight months.
Okay, two years.
Two years.
That's the goal.
Two years?
Two years.
Should we try, Ruffians?
That might be really tricky, Domoco-chan, you know?
I think it might be tricky.
Three years.
Let's make the goal three years, okay?
I don't know if the math is good, but three years, okay?
Actually, I was taking a peek at some of our senpai's channels to see who has a thousand videos.
And I was surprised to see which senpai do and maybe don't.
Right?
But it also makes sense because they're very busy in lots of different ways, too.
Should we hope to also be busy, too?
We're gonna be busy.
But you know, it's also happy to be busy outside of YouTube too, so... Let's do our best!
I want everything too.
Greedy.
I'm greedy.
We'll continue to work hard here and outside of YouTube too, you know, whether it be streams or videos or sorts.
BAU BAU!
And it's also another special day.
It's a special day today, not just our first October FUWAMOCO Morning.
But, Ruffians, I don't know, maybe there's some Ruffians that realized it.
Ruffians, can you guess what special day it is today?
Okay, I'll give you a clue.
It is October 2nd.
October 2nd.
That's the day today.
It is.
It doesn't have to do with Monday.
Or Natto.
Not that much.
Korone-senpai's birthday was yesterday though.
Is it?
You know.
Special.
Okay, let's give it to them.
Okay, the Ruffians didn't call it.
Wow, I can't believe you didn't know this, Ruffians!
Okay!
Today is... Tofu Day!
October 2nd is Tofu Day!
It's Tofu Day!
Ten can be read in Japanese as To and Chu and Fu, so Tofu.
I bet you're surprised.
You didn't even know it was a day to celebrate, huh?
Tofu Day!
Toho Day would be cool too, but...
Not today, you know.
Yeah, you know, but tofu is so yummy!
I think there might be some Ruffians who think tofu doesn't have much flavor to it, but that's exactly why tofu is wonderful too!
You know, it's a blank canvas for your favorite flavors.
There's so many different things you can do with it!
Right!
You can make it spicy, you can make it...
If you like that, I guess, you can make a deep fry.
You can put it in the soup.
Oh yeah, you can deep fry it.
You can.
I just thought it might be dangerous.
Also!
It's not tofu, but it's like in the family.
The family.
The tofu family.
Soy milk!
Yeah!
Or as we like to call it, tofu milk.
Tofu milk!
Yeah!
We've talked about it before, but we really like soy milk.
My favorite is Kikkoman.
Yeah, Kikkoman.
You know when we were doing guard dog training in Japan?
At one point, we got so addicted to the black tea flavor that they would sell.
It was so bad at one point that we bought big cartons by the box.
By the box, yeah.
It's just so yummy!
But they have different flavors too, like not just the black tea flavor, not just the milk.
They have a lot of flavors.
And our second favorite flavor is the red bean flavor.
Ruffians, think of a flavor that you think would be good for soy milk.
Which flavor do you think would be enticing to you?
Never had tofu before.
Vanilla, they have vanilla!
Almond, they have almond!
Cucumber, they don't have that.
Banana milk, they have that!
Strawberry, they have that!
Strawberry, yes!
Matcha, yes!
Chocolate, yes!
Maple, I'm sure they must.
Pineapple, yes!
Sea chocolate, yes!
Azuki, yes!
So many flavors!
Lavender, maybe not.
It's a bit fancy, but maybe!
Light tea, yes!
Light sesame, yes!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Maybe one day we'll buy as many as we can and taste test them all for you!
Buy a lot of different flavors, you know?
It's a bit of a silly mini dream, but a big soy milk party and taste all the flavors.
It sounds fun, right?
Yeah!
You'll have to drink lots of soy milk with us too, Ruffians, okay?
Just a little tiny of each flavor, but it'll be a lot of soy milk.
BAU BAU!
Happy Tofu Day, Ruffians!
Let's all celebrate by eating tofu.
Yeah, don't have it this straight if you don't want that.
Not like this.
It looks like a block of paper.
BAU BAU!
Such a happy... Happy day.
Happy day.
But...
Ruffians.
To be honest, today, we thought we could maybe get to today without any misunderstandings, you know?
But accidentally, we made a misunderstanding ourselves.
We did.
Yeah.
Do you realize what we lost?
You realize we were trying so hard to not make any misunderstandings, too.
Aren't we always trying to avoid the misunderstandings?
We never cause them ourselves, right?
But, well, I guess... Ruffians!
Last FUWAMOCO Morning, there was something weird, right?
No.
Right?
You noticed it, right?
I think the Ruffians noticed it, Moco-chan.
I don't know.
Well, you know, there was no misunderstanding.
No mention of it.
Nothing!
Nothing at all.
We're sorry if we disappointed you.
But, but, it's okay.
Because, you know, there was none.
There was no misunderstanding.
Not until now, so, uh, yeah, uh, we had no misunderstandings last time.
Yay.
Do you think we could do this trick, Moco-chan?
No, no, no, no, because we inadvertently made another one by forgetting it last time.
Ruffians!
We'll try better next time, okay?
Yeah.
One day.
A future.
A future without misunderstandings.
One day.
It'll be a beautiful, sparkly day.
Celebrate with us, okay Ruffians?
Well Ruffians, it's the start of a new week for the fifth time.
The start of a new week, which means... Oh, oh, and it's also, it's also Tofu Day.
Extra.
Extra means that Moco-chan will be continuing to challenge herself to eat natto today!
Today this is Moco-chan's fourth time trying to eat natto.
To try to conquer.
To overcome it.
To challenge yourself.
I don't want the fluffiness!
I want the fuzziness!
No...
Oh no, just a little bit.
Just a little bit.
But yes, natto is really healthy for you.
And this is why we want Moco-chan to eat it.
I do want to eat it.
Okay, I do want to eat it.
But if you cook it, then you know you can continue to protect the Ruffian smile for many, many years to come.
Just like me.
But Ruffians, you feel inspired, right?
By my challenge, right?
Because I do want to eat it.
But this is difficult.
And I want to do it, but if someone wants to push me to it, I don't want to do it.
I feel inspired!
Right!
If you're hot, Mococo is working hard!
And something difficult that she wants to do!
Yeah!
So I'm gonna work hard too, right?
I think she's extra ready.
Cuz I'm doing it for you, okay?!
It's extra ready, Moco-chan!
What does that mean?
It smells very strong today.
Why?
Maybe just because this natto is very... It's the same.
Happy.
It's the same as always.
It's different, natto.
Tochigi!
I'm not stalling, I'm telling you my life story.
Well, you know, I've seen some Japanese Ruffians saying that maybe they should let Moco-chan put the tare sauce on top of it, but... You know, Moco-chan's strong, and I feel like it's more polite to the beans this way, too, so... Oh, it doesn't expire.
I think I can do it.
Natto doesn't expire.
It just gets dry, so it's not yummy.
But Moco-chan, today your goal is three beans.
I would like to sleep more.
No, because I wasn't able to eat three last time.
What's the extra bean, Moco-chan?
I don't have a tissue.
Okay, Moco-chan!
I'm not ready!
First, let's say thank you to the farmers in Tochigi!
Who worked very hard to make this.
Thank you, I know you worked really hard.
It's not gonna get wasted.
Just so you know, Ruffians, Fuwawa always eats it, so it's not wasted, okay?
Very important.
Okay, well, Moco-chan, here you are!
You're right, it does smell really strong today.
I have Moco-chan's favorite chopsticks for her, too.
No tissue, though.
I have a tissue.
No tissue.
Forget that.
I really want a tissue.
Tissue's not gonna go in your mouth.
It's the natto that's gonna... It's so neba neba today.
Take your virus from Tochigi.
Thank you.
It's so neba neba today.
Very slimy, huh?
Very sticky.
Once again, I'm looking for some good beans, okay?
Good beans?
They're all good though.
Particularly good beans, okay?
They're all good.
Are you sure you can't just, um, use... Get the neba neba off of it?
No.
Okay, Moco-chan, hurry up!
Hurry up!
I'm trying!
Don't call me a dude!
Why?
This is just one bean.
I'm trying to get them.
Are you going to go one bean at a time?
No, of course not.
I'm trying to gather... Why is it so neba neba?
Where's the non-neba neba one?
No, you need to eat them all.
I just smelled it a bit.
It just wafted over here.
I didn't even get close.
Wow, you didn't even give it permission to waft over here.
I didn't.
Why is it bad today?
Moco-chan already had something to eat, too.
I didn't.
Yeah, that's true.
Oh, I did!
I forgot.
I gave you soup, remember?
Okay, I'm trying to stack them.
Stack the beans like Tetris.
Moco-chan, that's playing with your food.
That's not good.
Ah, it's not!
Because they're sticky.
Wait, so the Tetris pieces are just sticky and they're not for you?
One second, one second, one second!
It's time, Moco-chan.
I'm not being evil, I'm being supportive.
Moco-chan wants to do this.
Moco-chan, you want to do this, right?
But I actually need a tissue.
Because I actually need a tissue.
I don't know what to do, Moco-chan.
I actually need a tissue.
What if you just eat it?
Don't use the tissue, you need to eat it, Moco-chan.
Every time you don't eat it.
It just goes in your mouth and then you spit it out.
It's not good.
I'm doing my best, okay?
That's not good!
You're serious about this, right Moco-chan?
I'm serious.
Are you?
Okay.
I don't know, Ruffians.
That's one... Three beans!
Oh, that is three beans.
I have confirmed that is definitely three beans.
Okay.
Okay Moco-chan, you're gonna do it!
I'm trying to get used to the smell because I was already done in by it, okay?
It's getting close.
I'm just trying to like, get used to it, okay?
Open wide, Mococo!
Not yet, not yet.
Moco-chan, you can do it!
You can do it!
Wow.
I don't know if I'm a Ruffian or not, but I sneezed five times in a row because my nose is very, uh, not working today, but now I feel like it is.
That's good.
See, good things happen when you have natto, Moco-chan.
I'm not waking today, but now I feel like it is.
That's good.
See, good things happen when you have natto, Moco-chan.
I'm just smelling it.
Okay.
I'm just
Okay, ready?
Should I chew it?
You should eat it, Moco-chan.
You know you need to chew to eat it.
Can you promise me I will have water after?
As long as I chew it.
As long as it stays in you, you know?
What?
That you eat it.
That doesn't go into the tissue.
Can I use the tissue on my tongue after?
Not on the tongue.
You can use it on your lips.
Like a napkin.
I wanna use it on my tongue.
No.
I'm trying to figure out my strategy, okay?
Moco-chan!
I'm trying, I'm trying!
It's been five minutes!
Fii!
No, no, no, no!
I'm stopping you.
Okay.
Please don't let the fish in.
I'm not stalling!
I am preparing.
Okay, Moco-chan!
Here we go!
10!
8!
No, 10!
2! 1!
I tried!
Give me a moment!
Do it!
Go!
In!
This is so pathetic.
Do it!
Moco-chan.
You're just opening your mouth and it's floating and then going away.
Moco-chan, don't think, just do!
Exactly!
I'm gonna turn off my brain, okay?
Turn it off!
You're eating!
Okay, brain off.
Brain off!
In it goes.
I can't turn it off.
My brain wants to stay on.
Mocoto.
I really want to try.
You want to do this, right?
You want to do this?
Okay.
3, 2, 1.
I want to do it.
Don't stop.
Don't, don't, don't.
Wait, Shizu.
Don't.
Wait, stop.
Okay, I want to do it.
I want to do it.
Here we go!
3, 2, 1!
It's in!
Oh, it got some strings.
Moco-chan's wiping her lips.
That's good.
Chew it!
Don't spit it out!
Oh!
Swallow!
You can do it!
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh?
Wait, you didn't chew it at all!
They just sat in there!
I tried!
I had it in my mouth for so long!
It was good, though!
I tried!
It was yummy!
I left tears, though!
I tried really hard, Ruffians!
That was another attempt.
Let's remember Moco-chan's struggles.
Moco-chan's struggles to overcome her hardship with natto.
And let's do our best to overcome our own troubles this week too, okay?
BAU BAU!
I tried.
Moco-chan, say BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
I tried.
You did, you did.
I need hand pads and I don't have water.
Give me hand pads and tissues with my tears and water, please.
Renato was in there for a while.
I was really excited.
I thought you could do it, Moco-chan.
Next time... Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Sky!
Look at Sky!
Look at the eyes!
It's like my eyes right now!
It's really cute, right?
Right?
It's like the eyes saying, I've had enough natto, can I go home now?
No!
No, you don't!
These eyes love natto!
They're excited!
They have energy!
They can do it!
Their eyes have a good time, right?
Right?
So cute!
Well, Moco-chan, how does Sky say BAU BAU?
I think that's Moco-chan's heart saying BAU BAU.
I don't know, I think it's when I got BAU BAU, right?
I think you know Sky?
Sky?
It's doing the best.
Yes!
It's good to go for walks, but... Yeah, all dogs are a bit different, right?
Ah, right.
And maybe Sky likes to be on the couch more than out in nature getting exercise.
Maybe some days.
That's fine, I guess.
Yeah, I think that's totally fine, you know?
So... But... I don't know.
On those days when we're just like, I don't wanna go outside, I think it's okay to just curl up on the couch, you know?
Today I went on a walk!
Where did this Ruffian go for a walk?
De-den!
It's Akihabara.
A walk in Akihabara!
Mansei Baishi!
This photo is from the Mansei Baishi bridge.
Looking gorgeous, kind of.
It's so pretty.
I don't know if we've ever seen it quite like this.
Really?
It's nice.
Very romantic.
Right?
I know!
Akihabara being Akihabara and everything.
You wouldn't think that there'd be a view this romantic there, right?
Mansei Baishi is nice.
But you know, I hope that you had a bunch of fun in Akihabara and that maybe you weren't too surprised when everything closed up and it got dark at around 8pm.
It always surprises us too, because Akihabara closes very early, right?
And you know, you just want to have more fun in Akihabara, right?
Too bad it closes rather early.
Gotta be quick.
BAU BAU!
And next we have the Question of the Day!
What question do we have today?
De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
Now that we are a few days in autumn... Moco-chan!
Same as last time!
This is not the question of today, this was the question of last time.
What's the question of today?
Hello FUWAMOCO!
I have a question.
Since I also have a twin brother myself, so I can't help but be curious.
Do you two have experience about sharing one thing between each other by taking a twin?
Do you two ever have a fight because of that?
Thank you!
Thank you for the question!
Sharing is the name of our lives, I think.
It's everything.
So I think we're pretty good at it, right?
Yeah, but sometimes we aren't!
No, sometimes we aren't, yeah.
But we do squabble about things here and there, but when we do it's always over-silly things like food or computer time or something like that.
But most recently, it was the Switch.
Yeah.
Ruffians, you know, right?
We know it!
Some Ruffians, because you saw us tweet, right?
Ruffians just said, oh, get a second Switch!
It's not easy, you can't do that!
No, it's not just like that.
You have to share!
That's not how you do it, Ruffians.
We don't use the Switch enough to get two Switches, that's silly.
But when we use the Switch, we both want to use the Switch at the same time!
Exactly!
So then we share it.
One round of Suika game, other round of Suika game.
Yeah.
But food, you know, that obviously needs to be very equal.
So, you know, if Fuwawa has a more delicious mushroom in her soup, then I want that.
It's a bit complicated.
It's not that easy, but you know, we just remind ourselves that we'll be all equal out in the end.
It's not a big deal, you know?
Even though sometimes it might be really hard to do that.
Just remember, you know?
Ruffians, you know how to share too, though, right?
You should.
It's a very important skill, okay?
Right?
But just keep on remembering, you know?
Sharing, you know?
It's important.
It's not worth creating your bond over that, so.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the question!
FUWAMOCO-chan.
You sure took a long time eating natto, so... Let's go fast here!
Our next theme!
Today we're going to be focusing on some homework and recording.
Going very, very hard on those.
But we'll be back tomorrow with... De-den!
Parasol Show!
Not the closing shit, Parasol Show!
Yes!
It's another very popular game from Chiyo's life.
Who made the closing shift that's why it's like this.
And we played it a few weeks ago.
I don't know, you know.
I feel like the closing shift wasn't all that too scary.
We made drinks.
I like that.
So we should be okay this time, right?
Ruffians, I don't know.
We might not need you to hold our paw this time.
Maybe.
I think maybe we'll be okay.
But please be there for us, okay?
We'll show you that we're strong, guys.
Thumbnail TV-8.
BAU BAU!
And take another look at our schedule.
De-den!
Well, on Wednesday we're gonna be starting the morning with
FUWAMOCO Morning.
But!
It's not just FUWAMOCO Morning.
We're gonna be streaming three times a day!
Three times!
We're sharing our morning together, and then in the afternoon, we're gonna be joining some of our Holo EN Senpai and Advent members together in Party Animals!
I'm excited!
Yeah, we're gonna be battling it out there together.
It's our first time playing that game too, right?
Yeah, we don't know who's gonna be joining, so it's a surprise.
It's a surprise.
And then,
We're gonna be starting out in Resident Evil 4 Remake.
You know, morning, afternoon in the middle, and night!
Three times!
Right?
It'll definitely be a very fun day, but a busy one.
So Ruffians, we hope that you'll be able to share your day, some of your time.
You'll be there for us too.
It's gonna be very fun, so... BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Kidokimi!
BAU BAU!
Taki-chan!
Zeke!
BAU BAU!
Divya!
Pin!
BAU BAU!
Oye!
Ayubi!
BAU BAU!
Wayschool!
Onochi!
BAU BAU!
Noccha!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!